alexa
is with us in california hi alexa
welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi babe it's a pleasure to speak with
you you too what's up
well after reading the total money
makeover my husband and i already
completed baby step
one and we are in the process of
starting baby step two
however um we're currently having some
problems living at home with my
mother-in-law and brother-in-law
and we're looking to move out our
initial plan was to stay there
uh our current resident and save up
money to pay off
well sorry uh pay off debt and save uh
and
work on baby step three but that seems
like it's impossible so my question for
you dave is
should we stay home and endure another
18 months of paying off debt
or should we look to move out and
still try to pay off our debt
okay the way you're phrasing that sounds
like when you move out you're going to
give up on your get out of debt plan
and i don't like that i want you to move
out
and i want you to ratchet up the number
of hours you're working
and tighten your budget down and rent
some cheap cheap cheap thing as cheap as
you can find i know you're in california
but i want you to give up on your get
out of debt plan
okay if you run out the door with your
hair on fire because you're mad at your
mother-in-law and you abandon your get
out of debt plan
and you wuss out on properly tightening
your budget down
and really being hardcore you missed the
point
okay i get being frustrated and getting
out of a toxic situation
i'm saying do it wouldn't you christy
yeah i i hear this a lot where people
feel like they only have you know if i
do this
i can't do this and that's not true you
can do both you can move out and get out
of debt people get out of debt all the
time that didn't
live with their mother-in-law you can do
this i think it changed i think it comes
down to changing the narrative in your
mind that that's not possible because if
you don't believe it's possible you're
not going to try
but if you start to realize like okay
what must be true we ask this all the
time dave
what must be true for me to get out of
debt and
pay a a reasonable you know cheap rent
but reasonable that we can afford
outside of living with my mother-in-law
you start to run those numbers you find
something that is just crazy cheap
you you know increase your income take a
side gig then you start to see how it's
possible yeah so if it takes you
uh you know an extra 12 months
so it's 30 months to get out of that
instead of 18.
so what i'm okay with that you got your
sanity and you moved out
you enjoyed your life in the process a
little more you know uh
but that but the way you phrased this
was
do i stay with crazy or do i just
move out and i hope it works out
now i'm gonna have a plan and i'm gonna
execute the plan
i'm gonna do both yeah you changed that
narrative exactly